digamos que queremos entender la
relación entre la cantidad de tiempo de
estudio y el porcentaje de aciertos en
un examen en un salón de clases de 200
estudiantes lo que podríamos hacer es
establecer grupos para los tiempos de
estudio y para los porcentajes de
aciertos y luego encuestar a los
estudiantes o revisar los resultados de
los exámenes y acomodar a los
estudiantes en estas celdas lo que vemos
aquí es una tabla de contingencia o de
dos dimensiones también la podemos ver
como una distribución conjunta a lo
largo de estas dos dimensiones entonces
es una forma de leer esto es que 20 del
total de 200 estudiantes obtuvieron
entre 60 y 79 por ciento de aciertos en
la prueba y estudiaron entre 21 y 40
minutos así que hay todo tipo de cosas
interesantes que podríamos tratar de
obtener a partir de esto pero en lo que
nos vamos a enfocar en este vídeo es en
otros dos tipos de distribuciones
distintas a la distribución conjunta que
vemos en estos datos un tipo es la
distribución marginal
y una distribución marginal solo se
enfoca en una de estas dimensiones una
manera de pensar en esto es al mirar el
margen entonces por ejemplo si deseamos
averiguar la distribución marginal de
cada porcentaje de aciertos lo que
podríamos hacer es mirar el total de
estos renglones así que estas cuentas
nos dan la distribución marginal del
porcentaje de aciertos 40 de los 200
obtuvieron entre 80 y 100 60 de los 200
o tuvieron entre 60 y 79 y así
sucesivamente ahora una distribución
marginal puede representarse como
cuentas o como porcentajes de modo que
si la representamos como porcentaje
tendríamos que dividir cada una de estas
cuentas entre el total el cual es 200
así 40 entre 200 sería el 20% 60 entre
200 sería el 30% 70 entre 200 sería el
35 por 120 entre 200 es 10% y 10 entre
200 y 5 % de modo que esto que tenemos
aquí entre
de porcentajes nos da la distribución
marginal del porcentaje de aciertos con
base en estos grupos así que podemos
decir que el 10% obtuvo entre el 20 y el
39 ahora también podemos pensar en la
distribución marginal en la otra
dirección podemos pensar en la
distribución marginal para el tiempo de
estudio en clase entonces veríamos estas
cuentas que tenemos aquí diríamos que un
total de 14 estudiantes estudiaron entre
0 y 20 minutos ya no estamos pensando en
el porcentaje de aciertos un total de 30
estudiaron entre 21 y 40 minutos de la
misma manera podríamos escribir esto
como porcentajes este sería 7% este
sería 15% este sería 43% y este de aquí
sería 35% ahora otra idea que a veces se
puede ver cuando las personas tratan de
interpretar una distribución conjunta
como ésta u obtener más información
acerca de ella es pensar en algo que se
conoce como una distribución condicional
distribución condicional es la
distribución de una variable dado algo
verdadero acerca de la otra variable un
ejemplo de una distribución condicional
sería la distribución del porcentaje de
aciertos dado que los estudiantes
estudiaron digamos entre 41 y 60 minutos
entre 41 y 60 minutos bueno para pensar
en eso primero vemos la condición bien
revisemos a los estudiantes que
estudiaron entre 41 y 60 minutos sería
esta columna que tenemos aquí y luego la
información de esa columna nos puede dar
la distribución condicional ahora una
cosa importante que debemos tener en
cuenta es que una distribución marginal
se puede representar como cuentas o
porcentajes para los diferentes grupos
mientras que la práctica estándar para
la distribución condicional es pensar en
términos de porcentajes de modo que la
distribución condicional del porcentaje
de aciertos dado que los estudiantes
estudiaron entre 41 y 60 minutos se
vería algo así
si establecemos las distintas categorías
de 80 a 100 de 60 a 79 de 40 a 59
continuamos aquí de 20 a 39 y de 0 a 19
lo que queremos hacer es calcular el
porcentaje que corresponde a cada una de
estas celdas dado que estudiaron entre
41 y 60 minutos así que este primero de
80 a 100 serían 16 de los 86 estudiantes
así que escribimos 16 de 86 que es igual
a 16 dividido entre 86 es igual a
sólo voy a redondear a una cifra decimal
es aproximadamente el 18.6 por ciento
18.6 por ciento y luego para obtener la
distribución condicional completa
seguimos haciendo esto encontramos los
porcentajes de 60 a 79 sería 30 de 86 30
de 86 cualquiera que sea el porcentaje y
así sucesivamente para obtener toda la
distribución hasta el próximo vídeo